so let me ask you something here do you  think it's right that a woman could  leave a relationship because of a man's  financial situation when she's got a kid  with the person no I think it's selfish  I think that's absolutely selfish if you  if you leave a Man based on his  financial situation when you have a kid  because when you have a kid it's not  about you anymore it's about your kid so  if your Maddie's not making enough money  and you're just gonna leave that's  selfish I believe that in that situation  it's me you're meant to be a team so if  someone's got you know if that's  happened to them you think you know what  I mean step up I'm gonna go and get  another another job another side hustle  we're going to work through this this is  what I'm saying if you're in a  relationship and you're got children  together or whatnot you're meant to be  doing that partnership anyway and that's  where the mindset should be at